you light it and they will write it
clark county inspectors enforcing the
ban on illegal fireworks jeremy j ford
at blue diamond and buffalo at the
opening there of a fireworks stand
tuesday is the first day of fireworks
sales in southern nevada and here at tnt
fireworks sales are taking place and
safety practices are being shared i
bought a bundle to support the
high heat baseball team here army
veteran george plankhart bought his
fireworks early from a reputable stand
and tells me he's against illegal
fireworks
he might pass infrastructure not just
for you but for the entire city of las
vegas nevada a reason for county
inspectors to enforce the ban on illegal
fireworks by making sure all booths
comply with county regulations all the
product inside the booth is actually
have a safe insane sticker on it some of
those include sparklers smoke balls
snake type fireworks and ground spinning
fireworks anything that doesn't shoot
into the air the fine starts at 500
dollars up to 10 thousand dollars
depending on the amount of power
techniques that you have on your
position with almost 40 inspectors out
working they plan to crack down on
illegal fireworks like i said contact i
spy if you already know you have a
situation because that will allow us to
create the data for the following year
jeremy j ford live local now